I know but what I mean both whispering
because I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why I've been on them I want to say this
yeah
and anyone listening right now and I
swear to [ __ ] god yeah I'm about to
say something that's more truthful than
anything I've ever [ __ ] said before in
my life
all right George is a piece of [ __ ] no
George is a good guy like that one I
love you so much it was so hard to say
that was so [ __ ] hard to say oh my god
I'm sorry my bad
we would call him there's a pink dick I
heard I've heard you had a pink dick but
I want to say this is the most truthful
thing I've ever said is is that people
listening right now Tiger belly found
saved my [ __ ] so I it saved me this
podcast and also it's reassuring that
you know if this show doesn't work or
whatever happens in my career doesn't
work that I I can oh I'm always gonna do
this that's one thing and no matter how
busy I get we're always gonna do this
Monday night and we release it on
Wednesday I don't know I don't know when
it comes out but yeah but but this thing
right here with Lindsey and stuff like
that I've never been in this position
before so it's exciting and a lot of
Tiger belly fans we're tuning in and
they were and and supportive and I just
can't I just I'm just you know thank you
everybody
I appreciate them it's nice to be like
doing something that you actually really
like you know I know people probably
like what are you talking about you're
so lucky you're on a TV show but like
when it actually feels good and the
people feel good yeah that you work with
and you have to spend time with and I
just have this paranoid that a real
place with Ken Jeong that's because of
the text yeah yeah like really what was
your thoughts when Bobby was late yeah
oh no what did you really think we were
all together as we're shooting a party
so it was the first time everybody was
there
yeah so the truth is because like every
minute that passes costs a gajillion
dollars and so we were all like it's
cool like he'll be here and as it we did
start to get cuz of course they're
calling you and everyone's calling you
and and then they sent someone to your
house and I was yeah what is happening
and all of our action was like I'm a
little nervous I'm like you are why and
then and then then I got nervous yeah
you know cuz you were you were like you
know really late we're at dinner yeah I
mean I I'm telling you right now I when
I was telling the story it's not a lie
it's number one if if you're 20 minutes
late it's a problem when you're hours
late right you're costing people money
people are paranoid they have to you
know P cuz when they do a show they
don't just improvise it they the
director and the production it's
scheduled days in advance where the
cameras are gonna go so they can be
proficient you know and and and milk the
day but when somebody's not there it
[ __ ] everything up like if we missed
your scene like if you missed if we had
to reschedule it it would mean an extra
day or adding it on and making it longer
to something else company move or like
yeah you would you think that well I
didn't think it all of us Oliver was
like D like maybe he relapsed or
something you know and I was like come
on Oliver that's yeah you know I
actually thought you know I thought
something like you must've overslept or
something if he thought I relapsed then
why send me a photo of us really thought
that yeah actually I was thinking
because you've said to me that you go to
the Korean spas you know like you go at
night yeah hours like maybe
we gotta grab he jumps right I didn't
think death I just thought like maybe
you had a particularly long and relaxing
night at the Korean spa but you know
honestly what you said to me was that it
was usually sleep during the daylight
hours right so I was like well that's
it's he's free he's adjusting his you
know body clock and when when I was
trying to push him out the door he was
so afraid he almost didn't want to go to
set because he was like a little kid
like I don't want to go I'm so scared
he didn't want to hit you know
reprimanded and then and then it was so
weird because when we were shooting it
seemed like it was okay but as the days
went on I try to lock eyes with Emily
cap Nick executive producer that
apparently likes me so much he wouldn't
do this
and then she gave me a pass I'll tell
you what she did
so there's kids all of her kids were in
the scene remember that day it was a
party scene and there's kids running
around and I'm sitting there on a chair
right because I had to walk through like
a shot and I see Emily walked toward me
right right and she goes to my side she
pauses you know what she does she puts
her hand on my shoulder for about five
seconds that's a long time I know but
not like great job but like just a hand
was it firm no it was just a placement
of like a little bit of a what if I like
my shoulder was bleeding no she gently
put her hand on my shoulder right yeah
and then she laid it on there for about
four five seconds and she does a little
like tap and she walked away and we've
never just never been talked about she's
probably just really happy you weren't
dead yeah we all were
Oh what would happen if I did die
I can't even let's not even talk about
what happens I want to just then that in
there it well it clearly can no I think
your airplane
I think they would have got Steven Yeun
what is switch look exactly alike
yesterday we look exactly that's true
yeah yeah
[Music]